i
[Música]
estado mental resiliencia la capacidad
de entender que el problema es el
disfraz favorito de la oportunidad
mi vecino omar
era el de en medio de una familia de
cinco hijos una familia marginada como
las que había en el barrio
él empezó a dibujar cuando su hermano
mayor entró el primer centro de
rehabilitación
no paro
ahora es uno de los creativos de una de
las empresas más importantes en el mundo
generadora de videojuegos hace lo que
ama tiene un departamento propio el
resto de sus hermanos
uno entró a las filas del narcotráfico y
fue asesinado en 2015 otro está en la
cárcel otro está en las drogas en la
calle otro hace algo que no ama y yo me
pregunte
qué hace que un individuo que creció en
el mismo cuartito de madera durmiendo en
las mismas literas hechizas en la misma
familia tuviera la capacidad de
conseguir su éxito personal
será algo genético porque si es algo
genético entonces la vida es injusta
unos nacen con eso y otros no
será una cuestión de estímulos escuchó
vio sintió algo en el momento adecuado
si así fuera podemos replicar estos
estímulos es así de importante imagínate
que supiéramos qué fue lo que hizo que
omar tuviera esta capacidad de
resiliencia podríamos hacer que más
personas en el mundo alcancen su éxito
social así que me di a la tarea de
seguir a un sujeto de prueba durante
diez años ese sujeto de prueba soy yo
pudo haber sido alguien mejor si pudo
haber sido más barato no
así que les voy a pedir disculpas porque
voy a hablar sobre mí en el resto de la
charla porque soy mi propio conejillo de
indias
crecí en el mismo barrio que omar calles
de tierra casas de cartón de láminas
pude desarrollar mis habilidades empecé
a rapear cuando tenía 16 años luego por
cuestiones de la vida casi por accidente
me convertí en un activista o en un
promotor cultural
he estado en 18 países gracias a lo que
hago haciendo conciertos conferencias
talleres mesas de debate creando
plataformas que intentan cambiar el
mundo
pero lo más importante que he hecho es
conocer personas increíbles personas
inspiradoras y luego tener la fortuna de
que se convierten en mis amigos y ya
teniendo los de amigos puede realizar un
esquema de factores que teníamos en
común es lo que voy a compartir con
ustedes esta tarde
el primer factor en común que encontré
fue la estimulación temprana
algo que teníamos en común es que todos
teníamos libros alrededor ojo con eso yo
crecí en un cuartito de dos por dos de
madera pero mi papá tenía un librero con
quince o veinte libros mi mamá me enseñó
a leer antes de entrar al kinder eso
amplió mis horizontes desarrolló mi
creatividad también mis amigos tenían
estos estímulos tempranos
si pudiéramos hacer que los niños
tuvieran un contacto con los libros con
la literatura y desarrollaran su
creatividad podríamos hacer que
desarrollaran este tipo de cosas otra
muy importante es que los adultos que
teníamos alrededor nos dijeron que
podíamos ser quienes quisiéramos ser que
podíamos cambiar el mundo y no lo
dijeron tantas veces que les creímos nos
lo dijeron tantas veces que lo estamos
intentando
otro de los factores que tenemos en
común es la semilla de la duda a
nosotros no nos enseñaron certezas no
nos enseñaron verdades absolutas no nos
crearon a través de una ideología nos
enseñaron a dudar
y la duda es la sombra de la verdad nos
enseñaron a cuestionarlo todo inclusive
a los mismos adultos e inclusive a los
libros que habían sido nuestras guías
inclusive dudar de nuestro de nosotros
mismos porque porque esa es la forma de
desarrollar un criterio individual es
nuestra capacidad de discernir el mundo
y nuestra realidad esa herramienta es
importantísima la duda es un pigmento
que oscurece poco a poco a las ovejas
hubo más cosas que encontramos en común
el despertar de la conciencia todos
recordábamos el momento exacto en el que
tuvimos este el mío
estoy bajando de una sierra en chihuahua
en un vehículo cuando mi hermano me
llama y me dice está sentado y yo le
dije sí
me dijo nuestras habilidades y nuestros
dones deben ser utilizados en beneficio
de la humanidad no en nuestro beneficio
individual
cuando me lo dijo lo entendí
perfectamente porque en el fondo ya lo
sabía pero me cayó todo el peso de la
responsabilidad encima le dije gracias
por arruinarme la vida nos reímos de eso
cuando nos acordamos
cuando entiendes que muchos seres
maravillosos dieron su vida para que
nosotros estemos aquí para que yo use
este micrófono para que exista el
internet para que tengamos los lujos que
tenemos ahora la libertad que tenemos te
das cuenta que hay que ser agradecidos
can dijo trabajemos en nuestro espacio
tiempo hay que seguir empujando esa
rueda del progreso humano es nuestra
responsabilidad para las futuras
generaciones
la des victimización
cuando entré a trabajar por primera vez
a la cárcel para menores el rector no
nos tenía mucha fe porque un taller de
rap en la cárcel nos dio el grupo más
conflictivo
en tres meses logramos convertirlo en el
grupo modelo lo que hicimos es sencillo
nadie quiere ser una víctima no siempre
estamos buscando echarle la culpa a
alguien nuestros padres el sistema la
pobreza los illuminati lo que tú quieras
la lista es larga pero cuando le dices a
alguien que creció en el barrio o en
posibilidades desfavorables que
prefieres ser un factor de tu entorno o
una víctima de tu entorno nadie quiere
ser una víctima y cuando se des
victimizan los individuos se hacen
responsables de su propia vida ha sido
importante esa
la resignificación de conceptos yo
trabajo con las palabras soy un
palabrero me he convertido en su abogado
ahora tengo un proyecto que es limpieza
de palabras algo que teníamos en común
con estos amigos de los que les platico
es que intentaron insultarnos con
palabras como ustedes son muy ambiciosos
porque han confundido a la ambición con
la avaricia la avaricia es la búsqueda
incesante de tener más de lo que
necesitas pero la ambición la ambición
te hace pararte todos los días de la
cama intentar ser una mejor persona
progresar alcanzar tus metas
nos llamaron egocéntricos
pero sin ego yo no podría estar parado
aquí frente a ustedes no hubiera hecho
mi primer canción mi primer proyecto
el ego es nuestro primer fan solo hay
que cuidar que no se convierta en
nuestro manager y todo va a estar bien
la razón como codificador de la realidad
esto no es la única forma de codificar
la realidad hay muchas pero es la que me
funciona a mí porque lo que quiero hacer
debe ser comprobable debe ser basado en
el pensamiento científico quiero hacer
un cambio pedagógico académico a través
de lo que hago entonces necesito a la
razón porque es la comunicación
universal y otra cosa en común que tengo
con estos amigos es que todos utilizan a
la razón como ese codificador de la
realidad y también crecieron donde a mis
tías le jalaban los pies y en mis tíos
se les apareció el y todo eso
pero había que cuestionarse luego en
algún momento
pensamiento mágico versus pensamiento
crítico uno de estos amigos es victoria
dio victoria al admiro muchísimo un día
me dijo danger s focus rojo que ves allá
afuera se lo decrete al universo hace un
año y aquí están las llaves
qué me dices de eso y yo le dije se lo
decreta este al universo y te quedaste
sentada ahí donde estás y apareció ahí
afuera no verdad trabajaste para
conseguirlo cuando uno decreta algo
hace una programación neurolingüística
en su cerebro es muy importante los
pensamientos tienen este poder programan
tu cerebro cuando yo hablo de estado
mental no hablo del secreto hablo de
neurociencias y de conexiones eléctricas
entre tus neuronas pero es súper
importante encadenar la idea a la acción
a mí se me ocurre algo y lo hago me
equivoco aprendo y regreso eso tenía en
común con mis amigos fundé un proyecto
que se llama sujetos del verbo que es lo
mismo un juego de palabras encadenados a
la acción
un día se me ocurrió un estudio de
grabación móvil porque la gente donde yo
crecí no puede pagar 80 dólares la hora
pero son muy talentosos vi un camión
parado en una institución municipal
un amigo me pidió un proyecto con poco
presupuesto unos amigos tenían cosas
para un estudio móvil así que conecte
los puntos y metió un estudio de
grabación a un camión creé una página
web
recibimos canciones grabadas en el
celular y nos fuimos a los barrios
después de seleccionar a los más
talentosos grabamos muchos demos gratis
a mucha gente que pudo afianzarse a
seguir sus sueños a seguir la música hay
que encadenar las ideas a la acción vale
para ayer
me asusté cuando el secretario de
seguridad pública de mi ciudad me mandó
llamar
era un hombre muy poderoso me senté a su
mesa y me dijo danger he visto lo que
haces en los barrios más llamaba la
atención de los medios de comunicación y
yo quiero saber para cuándo puedes
tenerme un proyecto de prevención de
violencia a través de la cultura urbana
yo le contesté para ayer todos en la
mesa se rieron uno de ellos después me
confesó que cuando me fui de ahí el
secretario dijo necesito gente así
alrededor de mí con esa actitud actitud
es un sinónimo para estado aumentar
hay que hacer las cosas antes de saber
cómo hay que movernos y hay que aprender
en el camino como les dije pero hay algo
importante se lo que quieres ser ojo con
esto yo era un rapero famoso antes de
que alguien me pidiera una foto
yo era un promotor cultural activista
exitoso que viajaba por el mundo
intentando hacer del mismo un lugar
mejor antes de que nadie lo supiera más
que yo
pero me levantaba todos los días a las 7
de la mañana a engrosar mis proyectos a
salir a la calle a tocar puertas ya era
lo que quería hacer antes de serlo eso
es otra cosa en común que tengo con mis
amigos quieres convertirte en algo
empieza a actuar como eso
es importante que entendamos cómo
funciona el estado mental cómo podemos
programarlo repitiéndonos lo que
queremos pero trabajando para alcanzarlo
una vez que lo programe una vez que te
conviertes en lo que quiere ser ya no
hay vuelta atrás pero tienes que tener
cuidado porque conlleva una
responsabilidad
a mí me llamó una vez de los ángeles el
director de un proyecto muy importante
en el mundo se llama homeboy industries
ellos sacan jóvenes de las pandillas y
de las cárceles y los re integran a la
sociedad les enseñan un oficio etcétera
estar bien para ayudar a los demás se
llama esta parte me dijo danger necesito
que vengas me des unos talleres y una
conferencia de tu experiencia de vida
para este proyecto cuánto me cobras
yo le dije nada he escuchado mucho de lo
que hacen y quiero aprender hoy gratis y
me pregunto eres rico le dije no todo lo
contrario me dijo acá hablamos vende no
cuando entré a su oficina me dio 500
dólares y me regañó me dijo
tú no necesitas nada elige si de hecho
en esa época yo comía una vez al día y
me dijo
tienes que estar bien tú para ayudar a
los demás si no estás bien tú no me
sirves a mí y no le sirve a nadie
esa es una elección muy importante para
la gente que quiera dedicarse al
activismo oa las plataformas sociales lo
que le damos a los demás nos lo damos a
nosotros mismos uy esto desmitifica el
altruismo la labor social y el activismo
no lo hacemos porque somos madres de
calcuta lo hacemos por sentido común la
responsabilidad de que alguien lo hizo
antes que nosotros y entender que es
mero utilitarismo yo hago de este mundo
un lugar mejor porque vivo en este mundo
vamos a desmitificar eso sí a entender
como un sentido común y hacer
responsables todos y hacer nuestra parte
todo se crea dos veces
cuando hice mi primer proyecto primero
lo hice aquí en mi cabeza luego busqué
la forma de materializarlo
es importante que entendamos que como
todo se crea dos veces cuando aparece en
mi cabeza ya existe una vez y está a un
paso de pasar al plano físico pero si no
pasa no existe tienes que crearlo dos
veces para que exista pero ojo esto
también funciona a la inversa tus
pensamientos negativos son igual de
poderosos que tus pensamientos positivos
yo creía que estaba enfermo hace unos
años y luego estuve enfermo de verdad
ansiedad generalizada pensamientos
negativos depresión pensamientos
negativos
una vez que creas una vez en tu cabeza
un problema solo está a un paso de
materializarse tengan cuidado sean sanos
de la cabeza por favor encuentra el área
que cruza tu pasión y tu talento
yo y mis amigos fuimos afortunados
lo encontramos temprano algunos no hay
un parque tardo pero pudo desarrollarse
rápido porque la respuesta está aquí
mucha gente me pregunta yo no sé cuál es
mi talento yo no sé cuál es mi pasión
que hago estudia aprende edúcate eso va
a ampliar tus horizontes ahí lo vas a
encontrar y cuando lo encuentres vas a
estar mejor preparado para desarrollarte
ahí
así que hay que encontrarlo porque
cuando lo encuentres todo va a tener
sentido no vas a volver a trabajar en
algo que no amas ningún día de tu vida y
no te tendrás que sobre esforzar porque
todo fluirá como fluye el río y como
fluye el viento vale hay que
encontrarnos
yo formo parte soy embajador en méxico
de una asociación internacional que se
llama generation hip hop
estamos en 57 países y trabajamos en la
transformación social a través de la
cultura urbana del movimiento hip hop
algo que va a pasar y que ya está
pasando es el networking gente
conectándose con agentes de cambio
cuando yo tenga un proyecto viable lo
subo a una nube
y esa nube que está conectada con muchos
agentes de cambio alrededor del mundo
pueden descargar el proyecto que yo hice
a mí me gusta algo que están haciendo en
australia lo bajo y lo aplicó en mis
políticas locales eso va a pasar una
revolución mental a través de agentes de
cambio y espero que muchos de los que
están aquí sean algunos de ellos gracias
bueno como soy rapero y campeon de
improvisación de versos me pidieron que
rimar algunas palabras que ustedes
escribieron les gustaría o no
para uno
voy a sacar dos para improvisar las dos
esperanza sí
ustedes son los que vuelcan la balanza
los que acercan el infinito al uno
estamos juntos tirando esta lanza y va a
llegar al objetivo en el momento
oportuno ustedes son los que caminan y
no se cansan aunque no hayan tomado el
desayuno claro que se siente la
esperanza en este sitio te ves en el
paro no
2 más fuego y naranja
levante la mano quien escribió eso por
favor
gracias
fuego y naranja ustedes saben que a la
creatividad ahora le llamamos esto de la
empresa naranja
podrías
caer en una zanja podrías perderte luego
podrías no cruzar la franja de la
inspiración por miedo
a veces la esperanza se raja se raja a
veces siento que no puedo pero con mi
creatividad pinto al mundo de naranja
luego de rojo le prendo fuego
últimas 2
últimas dos últimas dos
aprendizaje qué bonita
felicidad guau riman solas esas dos
aprendizaje y felicidad
voy a emprender un viaje
con el que me quiera acompañar
solo llevamos un cambio en el equipaje
pero es el cambio de mentalidad
no necesitas traje puede vestir como es
en realidad
porque si tiene aprendizaje tendrá amor
y felicidad gracias
[Aplausos]